on nous le répète assez souvent une
bonne partie de ce que nous sommes et
déterminé par nos gènes ces gènes on les
a hérité de nos parents la fécondation
est a priori bas pas moyen d'en changer
et pourtant à la fin de la seconde
guerre mondiale aux pays bas il s'est
passé une chose étrange pendant l'hiver
44 45 dans le nord-ouest du pays
il ya eu une famine provoquée par un
blocus allemand et elle a fait environ
20000 morts chez les néerlandais
mais outre les morts directs cette
famille n'a eu aussi des conséquences
sur les descendants des survivants
soixante ans plus tard on a remarqué que
les petits enfants des femmes enceintes
pendant la famine était plus petit plus
gros et plus susceptibles de tomber
malade que les autres enfants d'âge
équivalent les petits enfants c'est à
dire que les effets de la famine ont
persisté sur au moins deux générations
après l'événement comment on peut
expliquer ça c'est comme si la famine
avait altéré les gènes des survivants et
s'était transmise à leurs descendants
aujourd'hui on pense qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'un phénomène génétique mais
épigénétiques et on va voir que la
différence est importante pour
comprendre ce qu'est l'épigénétique il
va falloir aller à l'intérieur de nos
cellules
et pour ça j'ai demandé un coup de main
à petite jeanne qui anime l'excellente
émission une cellule aux alors petite
jeanne qui nous présente la chaîne salut
david c'est moi on parle de biologie
cellulaire histoire de comprendre
comment tout ce petit monde de notre
corps fonctionne bon je parle aussi
d'autres choses mais pour aujourd'hui
promis je surveille mon langage et on
reste sur la bio maintenant que les
présentations sont faites plongeon au
coeur de nos cellules
[Musique]
commençons par les bases comme vous le
savez sans doute dans nos cellules le
support chimiques de nos gènes c'est
l'adn l'adn c'est une longue séquence
constitué de quatre bases nucléotides
adénine guanine cytosine thymidine qui
sont reliées entre elles par la
structure en sucre désoxyribonucléique
ans scott pour tous nos différents gènes
comme un plan de montage de toutes nos
protéines bien à l'abri dans le noyau on
retrouve deux brins adn complémentaires
comme de copies de sauvegarde la denim
ça semble alors avec la thymine et la
guanine avec la cytosine formant les
barreaux de la fameuse structure en
double hélice de l'adn le long de la
séquence un gène code pour une protéine
est un gros complexe protéique appelé la
rn polymérase va permettre de lire l'adn
et d'assembler la rn correspondant c'est
l'étape de transcription la rn un seul
brin cours avec une structure henry buzz
est suffisamment petit pour sortir du
noyau de la cellule il sert alors de
messager entre le plan de montage dans
le noyau et le site e place où se
trouvent les usines à protéines les
ribosomes série hbo zone des codes la
séquence de la rn et assemble les
protéines pendant l'étape de traduction
les protéines ainsi produite à partir de
nos gènes sont un peu comme les
ouvrières de nos cellules
elles ont tout un tas de rôle différent
pour permettre à notre organisme de bien
fonctionner un point clé c'est que quand
une de nos cellules se divisent l'adn
qu'elle contient et répliqué à
l'identique et donc toutes les cellules
de notre corps contiennent le même adn
alors bien sûr il peut y avoir des
mutations génétiques des variations des
bases à tg ou c mais celle-ci
intervienne de façon ponctuelle et
aléatoire d'une cellule à l'autre
et à part ça c'est donc essentiellement
le même adn on retrouve dans toutes nos
cellules et à première vue ça peut
paraître bizarre
par exemple un neurone fonctionne de
manière extrêmement différente d'une
seule du foie ou de la peau si toutes
les cellules ont le même adn
elle devrait fabriquer les mêmes
protéines et donc fonctionner de façon
équivalente n'en est bien non car ce qui
fait la différence c'est que chaque
cellule n'exploite pas l'ensemble des
gènes contenues dans son adn selon la
fonction de la cellule l'endroit où
elles se trouvent dans notre organisme
notre âge ou le fait que nous soyons en
train de dormir ou digérer les gènes
utilisés par chacune de nos cellules
vont varier
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'expression des
gènes chaque type de cellules exprime
utilisent des gènes qui lui sont
spécifiques mais
si certains gènes sont utilisées dans
presque toutes les cellules ce qui
permet à une cellule d'exprimer les
gènes dont elle a besoin
ce sont souvent ce qu'on appelle des
facteurs de transcription il s'agit de
protéines qui permettent de stimuler ou
contre ea d'inhiber la transcription des
gènes en arn et donc la production des
protéines associées à ce gène est
finalement ce qui va faire la différence
entre par exemple un neurone et une
cellules du foie
ça n'est pas des variations dans leur
adn mais dans la manière dont celui ci
va être lui est utilisé et pourtant dans
les années 70 on a découvert que les
cellules vivantes utilisait d'autres
mécanismes pour changer l'expression des
gènes des mécanismes qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui épigénétique
car ils sont capables de modifier la
molécule d'adn elle-même sans pour
autant toucher à la séquence des bases à
gt et c'est l'exemple le plus connu
c'est la méthylation de l'adn le méthyle
c'est un petit morceau de molécules qui
peuvent venir s'accrocher entre autres
au niveau des basses c'est de l'adn
quand des groupes mettent ils viennent
se fixer ainsi ils gênent le processus
de transcription de l'adn en arn et
diminue donc la production des protéines
associées aux gênes où ils sont
accrochés
cela peut avoir pour effet de
complètement éteindre le gène concerné
comme si on avait mis du scotch sur le
plan de montage il existe d'autres
marques a repis génétiques non pas sur
la molécule d'adn n en elle même mais
sur les protéines qui la structure pour
faire entrer une séquence de trois
mètres de long dans un noyau d'à peine 1
centième de millimètre de large
l'adn doit être extrêmement condensé
pour ça l'adn s'enroule autour d'un
groupe de huit protéine appelée des
histones et forme une structure en
collier de perles plus ou moins resserré
certains facteurs de transcription
peuvent contrôler cette condensation
il ajoute nous enlève un groupement
méthyle ou un groupement à sept-îles un
autre petit morceau de molécules
directement sur les histones la
combinaison de tous ces groupes sur
l'adn et sur les i stone contrôler
l'état de compaction du collier de
perles qui joue un rôle important dans
l'expression des gènes lorsque l'adn est
trop con lancé le complexe de
transcription ne peut plus accéder à la
séquence de l'adn pour la lire tout
simplement pour des raisons spatiale
ces modifications peuvent être
transitoire permettant à la cellule de
réguler finement certains gènes en temps
réel pour pouvoir s'adapter à son
environnement
mais dans d'autres cas ces marqueurs
épigénétiques peuvent être plus
permanent par exemple chez les hindous
du porteur de deux chromosomes x
classiquement de sexe féminin
léger a une portée par ses chromosomes
pourrait s'exprimer deux fois plus que
chez les individus x y
ce qui pourrait poser des problèmes pour
éviter ça l'un des deux chromosomes x
est compact et de façon stable via
notamment une méthylation importante de
l'adn et des histones cette inactivation
au hasard d'un des chromosomes x a lieu
très tôt dans le développement
embryonnaire mais elle est maintenue
dans les cellules tout au long de leurs
divisions successives
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que seuls les
chattes peuvent porter trois couleurs
les couleurs noires et rousse et en deux
versions d'un même gène portait sur le
chromosome x
les taches sur le pelage marque alors
les hommes de cellules dans lesquelles
l'un ou l'autre des chromosomes a été
inactivé vous voyez donc en plus de nos
gènes
il existe un certain nombre de marques
épigénétiques susceptibles d'influencer
leurs expressions et ces variations ne
sont pas rares prenez des jumeaux
homozygotes ce qu'on appelle des vrais
jumeaux ils sont issus de la même
cellule oeuf et ont donc le même adn
mais leurs marqueurs épigénétiques
peuvent être assez différent une étude
publiée en 2005 a montré que les
différences épigénétiques entre vrais
jumeaux augmentait avec l'âge
qu'il s'agisse de la méthylation de
l'adn ou de la setil ation des histones
si des jumeaux de 3 ans sont quasi
identiques de ce point de vue des
jumeaux de 50 ans peuvent avoir des
niveaux de marqueurs épigénétiques très
différents et ce d'autant plus que les
deux jumeaux ont eu une histoire et un
mode de vie différent et bien sûr si on
parle de ses marques épigénétiques c'est
que comme les variations génétiques
classiques elles peuvent avoir des
vraies conséquences sur les organismes
et leur développement
il existe par exemple une fleur appelé
lunar ya voulgaris la linière commune
qui existent en deux variantes de forme
la forme classique possède une symétrie
axiale tandis qu'une forme moins
courante à une symétrie radial la forme
que va adopter la fleur est contrôlé par
un gène mais ce gène est strictement
identique dans les deux cas ce qui fait
la différence c'est que dans la forme
asymétrie radial il est fortement
métissée et donc il est inactivé ce qui
différencie ces deux variantes de la
fleur ça n'est donc pas une mutation
classique du gène c'est la présence des
groupes méthyle on parle parfois dépit
mutation si les animaux aussi les
conséquences peuvent être importantes
dans le modèle de souris avis la couleur
du pelage change en fonction de la
méthylation du gène
à guti passant du jaune en absence de
méthylation au noir ou pseudo abouti
lorsque l'adn est très mé il est de plus
alors que les souris pseudo agoutis
maintiennent un poids normal tout au
long de leur vie
les souris jaune ou tacheté deviennent
obèses en vieillissant ceci est donc
contrôlée non pas par le gène agoutis
lui-même mais par son état de
méthylation encore plus fort en 2006 une
équipe de chercheurs a nourri des souris
avis gestantes avec un régime riche en
noms en gilet in une molécule qu'on
retrouve dans le soja par exemple les
souris nourries avec le régime riche en
plus de petits pseudo abouti c'est
sourisseau présente une hyper
méthylation du gène maintenu tout au
long de leur vie et un risque plus
faible d'obésité à l'âge adulte
le régime alimentaire in utero peut donc
affecter durablement l'expression de
certains gènes en modifiant de façon
permanente l'épigénome et ceci peut
avoir des conséquences importantes sur
l'état santé tout au long de la vie mais
évidemment pour que ces effets demeure à
l'échelle d'un organisme entier il faut
que la méthylation persiste lors des
divisions cellulaires et donc se
maintiennent pendant la réplication de
l'adn est justement pour cela il existe
une enzyme spécifique dnm t1 qui se
charge lors de la réplication de l'adn
de méthyle et le nouveau brun et donc
les mutilations sont conservés comme le
seraient les mutations génétiques
classique et pourtant une différence
importante entre les épis mutations et
les mutations classique c'est que les
épis mutations sont facilement
réversible
ce sont juste des marques sur l'adn
elles peuvent donc facilement être
ajouter ou enlever un autre aspect
essentiel des épis mutation et qui peut
paraître surprenant au premier abord
c'est qu'elles peuvent série t être
transmise à la descendance un bel
exemple baisse est celui des fleurs dont
je vous ai parlé l'inr commune
si une fleur a subi une mutilation qui
fait qu'elle adopte une forme radial ça
sera le cas aussi de ses descendantes en
se reproduisant la plante ne transmet
pas seulement ses gènes mais aussi les
marques épigénétiques porté par son adn
et l'état méthylé du gène peut se
maintenir ainsi de génération en
génération mais ça reste réversible
ainsi aux premiers stades de croissance
pour une raison ou une autre
laplante père la méthylation de ce gène
est bien le se développera avec une
symétrie axiale
si les animaux ce n'est pas aussi simple
la méthylation de l'adn est effacé
entre deux générations non pas une fois
mais deux l'adn est ainsi entièrement
des métiers pendant la formation des
gamètes ovules et spermatozoïdes et une
seconde fois lors des premières étapes
du développement embryonnaire
pourtant il existe bien des exemples de
transmission des plis mutation les
mécanismes ne sont pas encore très
claires mais ça pourrait passer par le
maintien des marquages épigénétiques dei
stone par des processus impliquant des
petits arn régulateur ou encore par
d'autres marquage épigénétiques encore
inconnue ainsi le statut de méthylation
du gène à guti et ses conséquences
physiologiques se transmettent sur deux
générations avant d'être perdu de la
même façon l'exposition de souris
gestantes par des perturbateurs
endocriniens perturber la fertilité
masculine de la descendance pendant au
moins quatre générations
ces perturbations sont encore une fois
non pas liées à des modifications de
l'adn mais à des altérations du profil
de méthylation de celui ci mais des épis
mutation pourrait elle être maintenue de
façon plus stable que seulement quelques
générations pour répondre à cette
question des chercheurs ont mis au point
des mouches dans lequel le gène
responsable de la couleur rouge des yeux
est plus ou moins exprimé selon des
marquages épigénétique
en croisant plusieurs générations de
mouches sélectionner ceux dont la
couleur de leurs yeux rouges ou blancs
on peut obtenir des épis ligne est
stable même après l'arrêt de la
sélection bien que les séquences adn de
ces mouches soit parfaitement identiques
elles transmettent le caractère couleur
des yeux à leur descendance pendant des
générations
via le maintien d'un marqueur
épigénétiques au début de l'épisode vous
ai parlé de la famille néerlandaise de
l'hiver 44 45
en vous racontant que tout semblait se
passer comme si les conséquences de
cette famine avait été héritée par les
générations suivantes
est ce qui pourrait donc s'agir d'un
mécanisme épigénétique
eh bien c'est ce qu'on suppose en
particulier des chercheurs ont pu
montrer des différences de méthylation
du gène ni gf2 qui est associé à une
hormone qui joue le rôle de facteur de
croissance chez les enfants ayant été
exposés à la famine quand il était
encore dans l'utérus de leur mère le
gène igf 2 et - méthylé que chez les
individus
du même âge qui n'ont pas connu la
famine et il existe d'autres études
analogue à celle de la famille
néerlandaise et qui suggère
l'héritabilité des marques épigénétiques
par exemple l'étude dite dover qu'elle x
alors over calix est un petit village
paumé dans le nord de la suède mais qui
a une particularité très intéressante
pour les chercheurs on y possèdent des
registres très bien tenu de l'abondance
des récoltes depuis des décennies en
plus des classiques registres d'état
civil et on a ainsi pu montrer qu'à over
qu'elle x les hommes dont le grand-père
a connu une période de disette de
faibles récoltes entre 9 et 12 ans ont
un taux de mortalité deux fois plus
faible que ceux dont le grand-père a
connu l'abondance au même âge
cette période de la croissance 9 à 12
ans étant très importante
on pense que l'alimentation a pu
influencer de façon déterminante
les marques épigénétiques des habitants
de work hélix et que ça a pu donc être
transmis à leur descendance et avoir des
conséquences sur leur santé
d'autres stress sont soupçonnés d'être
responsables de conséquence sur la
descendance via des altérations de
l'épigénome ainsi une étude sur dix
mille naissances a montré que des pères
ayant fumé avant l'âge de 11 ans avaient
plus de risques d'avoir des fils en
surpoids toutefois il faut rester très
prudent lors de l'interprétation
d'études sur des humains
y at il d'autres facteurs génétiques ou
socio culturel par exemple qui pourrait
expliquer la différence entre les
enfants issus de pères très jeunes
fumeurs et les autres pour éviter c'est
bien on doit s'assurer que le nombre de
cas de chaque groupe est suffisamment
grand et ajuster les différences
observées selon toutes les autres
caractéristiques de ces groupes à peu
près tout l'inversé de ce qui a été fait
dans une étude de 2015 qui étudiait les
perturbations de l'épigénome chez les
survivants de l'holocauste et leurs
enfants avec des groupes survivants de
l'holocauste et descendance très limité
32 et 22 respectivement
et des groupes contrôlent mal défini et
ridiculement petit 8 et 9 personnes
juives sans plus de précisions cette
étude a même été désignée études et puis
cinétique surinterpréter de la semaine
à sa sortie il est donc difficile pour
l'humain de séparer les effets
génétiques épigénétiques ou simplement
liés à l'environnement
souvent pour étudier ça on utilise des
populations de vrais jumeaux ayant été
séparés à la naissance
ayant grandi loin l'un de l'autre adn
identique mais marqueur épigénétiques
potentiellement différents mais même
ça reste difficile de distinguer
correctement ce qui relève de
l'épigénétique ou de l'environnement
familial et culturel au sens large
et puis il ya une chose étonnante et
perturbante avec ses histoires
épigénétique
c'est qu'elles ont un petit goût de neo
la marquise mme néo la marquise mme
revenons un peu sur la théorie de
l'évolution
on pense parfois à tort que l'idée
d'évolution a été introduite par darwin
il n'avait pas le cas un ce que darwin a
proposé de nouveau c'est le mécanisme de
cette évolution la sélection naturelle
avant darwin d'autres avaient déjà
proposé que les espèces puissent évoluer
et par exemple le naturaliste français
jean baptiste de la marque avait d'abord
suggéré un mécanisme différent
selon lui les espèces pouvaient acquérir
de nouveaux caractères s'adapter en
fonction de leurs besoins et de leur
environnement l'exemple de la marque
qu'on cite souvent est celui de l'âge
graf
d'après la théorie de la marque la
raison pour laquelle les girafes aurait
un long coup c'est qu'en étant dans un
environnement avec de la nourriture en
hauteur et bien cette pression aurait
poussé chaque girafe à s'adapter en
développant un coup un peu plus long que
les précédentes et cette variation se
produisant au cours de sa vie mais elle
pouvait ensuite la transmettre à sa
descendance
c'est une idée de la marque qu'on
appelle l'hérédité des caractères acquis
mais vous le savez ensuite darwin a
remplacé cette idée par celle de
sélection naturelle
ce que dit darwin c'est que ça n'est pas
que la girafe développe un coût plus
long sous la pression de son
environnement
mais plutôt qu'un jour du fait du hasard
et bien une girafe va naître avec un
coût un peu plus long ça lui donnera
peut-être un avantage par rapport aux
autres et donc plus de chances de
survivre et de se reproduire
bref au niveau des mécanismes de
l'évolution le la marquise mme
l'hérédité des caractères acquis a été
supplanté par le darwinisme la sélection
naturelle
mais si vous avez bien suivi vous avez
peut-être noté que l'épigénétique semble
se comporter comme le la marquise mme
votre histoire personnelle votre
environnement votre alimentation votre
comportement peuvent avoir une influence
sur votre état épigénétique
et ce dernier peut même être en partie
transmis à votre descendance
alors du coup est-ce que des caractères
acquis pourrait devenir héréditaire
c'est à dire est ce que la marque avait
aussi un peu raison et bien sûr le
papier oui et pour autant il faut rester
modérée car l'épigénétique ne va pas non
plus fondamentalement remettre en
question les principes de sélection
naturelle
on sait que les effets épigénétiques
reste réversible qui sont assez faibles
et que chez les animaux
on peut aujourd'hui difficilement
prouver qu'il persiste au delà de
quelques générations
en revanche s'il ya bien un domaine sur
lequel l'épigénétique pourra permettre
de nombreux progrès et pourquoi pas même
à l'avenir soigner des patients la
recherche contre le cancer
comme expliqué dans la très complète
vidéo de david sur le sujet le cancer
est une multiplication incontrôlée des
cellules de notre propre corps ya des
altérations au niveau cellulaire
classiquement on pensait que ces
altérations étaient surtout des
mutations de l'adn et c'est sur ces
mutations et sur les processus
cellulaires qu'elle affecte compte base
les thérapies mais depuis quelques
années on se rend compte de l'importance
de l'épigénome dans ce processus que ce
soit par des aberrations au niveau de la
méthylation de l'adn ou des
modifications des histones ou encore de
petits arn non codants régulant la
stabilité d'autres arènes et mieux
comprendre ces perturbations de
l'épigénome pourrait pourquoi pas à
l'avenir nous permettre de développer
des nouvelles stratégies thérapeutiques
comme vous le voyez sans être à ce jour
une révolution complète de la biologie
l'épigénétique montre des mécanismes
nouveaux qui influencent nos organismes
au-delà des effets génétiques classique
et pourtant gardé un esprit critique car
il semblerait que l'épigénétique soit
très à la mode chez les naturopathes les
thérapeutes quantique et toutes les
médecines alternatives de tout poil
alors non l'épigénétique ne va pas vous
permettre de rebooter votre génome en
buvant du jus de citron ou la graine de
yack merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo un
grand merci à petite jeanne pour sa
contribution et surtout n'oubliez pas
d'aller voir sa chaîne et vous y abonner
je vous la recommande vraiment vous
mettrai tous les liens qu'il faut en
descriptions à bientôt
[Musique]